In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 10th, on which we commemorate, the Holy Hyromarter
Joseph of Damascus.
Born in 1793 in Damascus, in a family originally from Beirut, St. Joseph Al-Hadad learned a little
Arab and Greek, but had to leave school early in order to help his father.
Filled with a great desire for learning, he worked during the day and spent his evenings
and nights reading and meditating on the Holy Scriptures.
Through this difficult labor, he acquired a deep knowledge of the faith.
Married at the age of 19, he was ordained priest when he was 24 years old by Seraphim,
Patriarch of Antioch, in the years 1813 through 1823, and then named Proto-Economos, chief
steward of the Patriarchate.
Through his apostolic seal and his eloquence which caused him to be called a second chrysostom,
St. Joseph was one of the first architects of the renewal of the Orthodox Church of Antioch,
which had been subject for centuries to Islamic oppression.
Convinced that this renewal could only take place through a return to the sources of Orthodox
spirituality, he undertook the correction or translation into Arabic of numerous scriptural,
materialistic, and liturgical texts, as well as actively participating in theological
debates with the representatives of Islam, of Eastern right Catholic clergy, and of Protestantism.
He founded a school in Damascus which afterwards took his name and he also taught in the seminary
of Balamond in the years 1833 to 1840, which has today become an Orthodox university.
The great majority of the hierarchs of the Church of Antioch in the second half of the
19th century were among his disciples and greatly profited from his teaching.
All in stature and timid, he was great in virtue and wisdom.
Remaining poor in imitation of the Savior who became poor for our salvation, he refused to receive
any money from the Church and his children had to work to provide for the needs of his family.
In July of 1860, during the massacres of the Christians of Damascus, all of the faithful
gathered together in the cathedral, which was destroyed during these events, and St. Joseph
encouraged them in fortitude.
The next morning, on the 10th of July, as he left his house to go to the church carrying
the holy gifts, a Muslim he knew recognized him and cried out, he is the leader of the Christians.
If we kill him, all the Christians will vanish into thin air.
They then fell on him and slaughtered him with axblows, together with a number of his faithful
followers tying a cord to his corpse and dragging it through the streets so that it would
be broken to pieces.
The blessed man thus sealed his pastoral ministry with the blood of martyrdom.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.